three weeks ago David took you through
the Mac flus from the late 80s Steve
Jobs was not a person that liked
hobbyist computing he really wanted a
smooth thing like this preferably as
impenetrable as possible he never really
heard the idea of upgrading things okay
he wasn't able to get the full version
of Adobe Acrobat 1 running because the
machine only has 2 point 5 megabytes of
RAM so we're going to do today is take
the machine to bits have a look at the
actual hardware inside this thing and
upgrade it to a full 4 megabytes of RAM
to make things harder just as Apple
still do today it uses Torx screws to
hold anything together they're going to
fuse a special Torx screwdriver but to
make things even harder and I'm sorry
Bob if you're in the way some of the
screws are buried right in the back here
so if your screwdrivers not long enough
you couldn't actually get them out and
so there used to be a lively trade back
in the late 80s and early 90s for very
long screwdrivers for removing these
things now I've already removed and lost
one of the screws from here so I've only
got a few more to take out so let me
just get the relevant screwdriver and
we'll get the back off this thing so
these two screws down here
another one over here and then there's
the hidden screw as always which is
behind the battery door here and I
suspect looking at the age of this
battery that that probably needs
replacing as well so we'll just get that
out so it's not a standard double-a as I
thought it was when I pulled it out it's
a 4.5 volt battery made in the USA I'm
sure if I looked online I'd find a
replacement
so we've now unscrewed the machine and
we can slide it apart and the way I
think it works is we slide the front out
from the back there we go and if we
slide the front out we can start to see
how it is inside so it's a CRT based
monitor so you can see the tube at the
back here and you'll notice that I'm
being very careful not to touch anything
in this area because even though this
machine's been off for a while there's
some huge capacities in here and the
voltages in here would probably throw me
across the room if I wasn't careful yeah
please don't try this at home unless
you're willing to die but perhaps an
interesting place to start is actually
in the back of the case B itself it
looks at first glance quite normal but
if we get the light in the right place
we can start to see that on the actual
back there are all the signatures of the
people who are involved in making the
actual original Macintosh I think that's
the great Steve Jobs is signature there
who are thinking as various other people
that we can see lying around so that's
the back of the case that's a few turn
ourselves back to the actual machine pop
that out of the way for now so we've got
various things this is the analogue
board and does the power so we got the
mains power coming in here generates of
voltages for the CRT and also provides
power down here to the actual digital
board here there's also a connector for
the floppy drive which I'm going to
remove their standard IDC connector now
this is where it gets slightly tricky in
that I've got a release this connector
here from the analog board to the
digital board this is
different really from a TV at the time
that in menu space it generates the
power takes the signal off the
motherboard converts it and drives the
CRT the electron beam floating around
and here the actual computer built
itself is buried on the digital board
but here so bear with me as I struggle
to remove the digital board and then we
can look at that in some detail so I'm
trying without destroying everything to
remove the power cable which I've got
one screwdriver in that side I'll get
another one in this side but there's a
whole lot of data traces the other side
that I don't want to scrape off the
motherboard wise it'll never work again
and then Dave won't be a happy Bernie
aha we've got that out now hopefully
it'll go back in later so we can now
slide out the motherboard from the
bottom and it comes out quite nicely I
should probably be wearing anti-static
stuff while doing this but let's live
dangerously so this is the heart of the
Mac plus and let's just take a second to
look around what we've actually got on
here most computers at the time had very
similar things good place to start is at
the center and this chip here the
Motorola 68000 is the CPU of the
computer it's not an IBM one it's
developed by a company called Motorola
it was a 16-bit chip but it was also a
32-bit chip and this is where it becomes
difficult to know whether to call it a
16 or 32-bit CPU it's got a 16-bit data
bus
but all this registers inside are 32
bits and so it's sometime referred to as
both 16 and 32 bits and there's long
description on whether it should be
referred to as a 16-bit or 32-bit chip
later versions in the family the 68020
68030 were for 32-bit chips with 32-bit
data buses a 16-bit data bus means every
time it transfers something to the rest
of the system it can send 16 bits in one
go so if we need to send 32 bits over to
the rest of the system it has to send
the first 16 bits and then send the
second 16 bits afterwards we've also got
here is a clock chip and this generates
a 16 megahertz
or 15.6 67 megahertz signal that is used
to synchronize everything together so
every time this beats the CPU we'll do
something else what else have we got
well we've got two chips here these are
the ROM chips and these are both 8-bit
ROM chips we're on high and run below
its contain the Macintosh operating
system so that's the Macintosh toolkit
so the full operating system because
some of that slowed in enough disk but
it's enough to actually get things
loaded in off disk and get things going
these are two 8-bit chips but they're
sort of used in parallel so this one
will provide one set of eight bits and
this one provide another set of eight
bits to form the sixteen bits of the
data bus the other thing we've got
turning it around so this is the RAM two
sets of Sims here tubes where these will
be one make Sims the other ones will be
256 K Sims giving us a total of 2.5
megabytes but I have got here for Meg of
Sims so for one megabyte Sims there's
eight of these on here each one of these
holds one mega bits worth of data
they're arranged in parallel to get
eight and we use them in pairs on the
motherboard to get our 16-bit wide
memory let's just pop these Sims out
he's not too dissimilar from dims and so
on we're using a modern PC but rather
than having two layers of connectors at
the bottom they just have a single set
of connectors so these are 30 pin Sims
single inline memory modules and along
the bottom you can see we've got these
silver connectors which will actually
connect in to the motherboard eight of
these connectors will carry the data
bits so it's got eight bit wide data bus
on these things a further 11 or the
address bus the others we've got things
like power and some of the addressed
rows whether it's a read or a write that
we've got let's just pop all these out
you have to be careful with this because
it's very easy as I found there's a
teenager to snap the connectors and then
you have to sort of superglue the sims
into this connections this was really at
the beginning of when Sims were used in
computers if you look at other computers
around from that time they were less
likely to use sims and was sometimes
just had the RAM chips soldered directly
onto the motherboard we can just pop
the new Sims into it like so I got these
off eBay it's still possible to get
spares for old computers there we are
and they just clip in and so on I don't
if you can get a closer but if you look
there's sort of teeth like things which
when they slide in make the electrical
connection
to the memory so that should now have
four megabytes worth the memory as
opposed to the two point five megabytes
that we had before not much bigger than
the average motherboard these days the
actual connections are a lot bigger and
so you can start to see how things
connect together and in fact if you can
just get a close-up you can start to see
all the wires connecting things together
here if we look on the back see if we
can find all 16 together da to see here
you can see well the address buses and
data buses connecting so he's got to
reassemble this and put it back together
and hopefully it'll turn on and have
four makes a memory slides back in these
two runners underneath somewhere it's
all clipped into yeah yeah that looks
nicely back together I flipped the hard
to ski and flip the keyboard a mouse in
and we can see if it's upgraded so it's
cozy with the hard disk lugs in here and
we've also got connections on the back
here for the mouth so I'll plug that in
you can turn it around look in power to
the two things look the keyboard the
front and the moment of truth so it
seems to be taking slightly longer to
boo to the road I suspect that's because
it's checking the memory and of course
it's now almost double the amount of air
we had before for Meg rather than 2.5 so
I have to wait for it to boot now it's
booted we can go into the about this Mac
or about the finder and you can see it's
got a four Meg of RAM as opposed to the
two and a half we had before so machine
still seems to be working and now with 4
Meg and hopefully Dave will be able to
upgrade his version of Acrobat
you
we reduce what we refer to as the
feature size of the component so we
reduce the size of the transistor or the
wire and of course if we have the
dimension of it then because it's a flat
surface
we quadruple by by for the number of
complains that is computer my kind of
late nineteen seventies early eighties
style but he's been knocked up with a
bit bold for a bit of fun